was there anything in it that actually
surprised you either in terms of the
punishment or the conclusions drawn by
the MPS
well two things that struck me first of
all uh I was impressed that the
Privileges committee put at the very
beginning of the report the importance
of telling the truth in Parliament and
how Central it was
to our democratic system and then the
rest of it it does seem to me to be very
evidently there are people complaining
that somehow Boris Johnson has had a bad
deal but it seems to me they have
followed the evidence and best their
recommendations and conclusions on the
evidence that they had before them and
uh there cannot be a more serious charge
of course and allegations that were made
uh about uh misleading Parliament
particularly by the most senior
politician in our country what could you
maybe maybe you could take the role of
the Privileges committee's introduction
to the report and explain to our viewers
why there is this necessity for our
politicians to tell the truth sometimes
I do hang around with ordinary people
and they make the point look politicians
they all lie so why is this individual
being singled out for this treatment
well I don't believe that they all do
lie uh so I don't accept that premise uh
as far as politicians are are concerned
I think the bulk of them do tell the
truth but the truth in politics is
Central to our democratic system because
people elect their members of parliament
to hold the government to account they
form the government from the majority
party and then MPS hold the government
to account if ministers and the Prime
Minister don't tell the truth how come
they hold them to account because they
haven't got the accurate information
upon which to make a judgment
still have the Privileges committee
perhaps lent some weight to Boris
Johnson's case that this is a kangaroo
court that it's all a pyramid an
inverted pyramid of piffle as I think
you refer to something else in the past
doesn't it perhaps lend a little bit of
weight to that to that claim given that
the extremity of the punishment that
it's handed down 90-day suspension from
the house plus that what at first glance
does look like the pretty churlish
recommended punishment of denying him
access to the House of Commons House of
Lords after he leaves the building
well it depends how seriously you take
the issue of misleading Parliament uh
there they say it's Central to democracy
of somebody who's undermining democracy
uh not only misled Parliament misled the
committee and then participated in a
campaign to uh intimidate the committee
that adds up to a pretty substantial uh
number of guilty charges against Boris
Johnson
and therefore I think a very serious
punishment uh was inevitable
there has been as there always is when
Boris Johnson finds himself in trouble
you know speculation about whether or
not he might make a return to politics
and I'm slightly less interested in that
that than the practicalities of him
having left Parliament before that
90-day suspension could be could be
stuck to it could be imposed upon him if
he were to return as a member of
parliament at some point in the future
would that 90-day suspension you know
still be pending well that's an
interesting point and I don't know if I
can give a definitive uh uh answer to
that but I think
that's considerable speculation about
him coming back into the house
in the near future the issue where as
the Prime Minister the head of the
conservative party
uh the courage to say given uh the
results of the Privileges committee is
it really possible for him to be a
conservative mp uh in in the future
uh we've seen the approach that each
summer
has taken about Jeremy corbyn uh and his
anti-Semitism
um
well we've got pretty serious guilty
charges here I would have thought the
conservative party would want to ensure
he did not come back as a conservative
MP
just just a final question to answer and
a lot of the criticism of this report
coming from Boris Johnson allies has
been directed at the fact that the
Harriet Arman was the chair of the of
the Privileges committee and did not
recuse herself if it was right for Chris
Bryant to recuse himself from from this
particular report what possible argument
would there be against Harriet Harmon
having to do exactly the same
well it of course the arrangements for
the Privileges committee provide for the
chair of the committee to come from the
official opposition which has got the
liver party
um
nobody challenged at the time when the
Privileges committee was set up and it
was known that Harriet ham was going to
be the chair nobody in fact in the at
the time it was put to the House of
Commons where it was passed unanimously
to set it up said that she should stand
down so uh
I think all the evidence is that she's
followed careful procedures uh they
publish what the procedures were going
to be they gave Johnson notice of what
their thinking was in an advanced report
and he had every opportunity to come
with any further Evidence he wanted to
bring forward they've come to unanimous
conclusion in fact two members would
have
had more serious punishment against
Boris Johnson so I don't think there are
any ground for him to complain and I
think it is about how seriously do we
take telling the truth as a central
value of our democratic system